a Michigan Police Department is
apologizing for failing to help a mother
who accidentally locked her baby in a
hot car
lacy guidance to month-old daughter got
trapped during a visit to Lacey's
grandmother's home last Saturday as lacy
tried to get inside the grandmother
called 911 dispatcher refused to send
help saying the police and fire
department don't unlock vehicles CBS
this morning Saturday co-host Michelle
Miller has new details of the scare and
scare indeed Michelle that was a
harrowing moment moments for this mother
good morning temperatures in Waterford
Michigan peaked at around 84 degrees
last Saturday when the incident occurred
that means the temperature inside lacy
Guyton's car could have been as high or
higher than a hundred degrees guidance
says what began as a great day visiting
grandparents turned into the worst day
of her life
nobody's coming and I don't know if I'm
watching my baby die right in front of
me lacy guidance to month-old daughter
Reina was in her car seat when she says
the doors to her dodge SUV suddenly
locked on a hot August afternoon the
keys were inside
I tried this handle it and then tried
that one and either of them were
unlocking it Guyton tried and failed to
smash the car's front passenger window
with a piece of asphalt her grandmother
called 9-1-1
but she says the dispatcher said the
department does not send emergency crews
to unlock cars and offered to send a tow
company instead so she's screaming and
crying which is making her hotter and
I'm still trying to break the window
after 10 to 12 minutes Guyton smashed
the back windshield with her
grandfather's window breaker climbed in
and got Reyna out on her own she says
Reyna was screaming and drenched in
sweat
it makes me feel terrible yeah you know
she had to go through that it makes me
feel so mad after calling twice the
dispatcher who's a veteran dispatcher
still didn't send somebody out it's
heartbreaking the Waterford Police
Department said in a statement to CBS
News that they do not normally respond
when people lock their keys in their
vehicle but we should have responded in
this case this is not the level of
service our
community has come to expect some 37
children died in heat-related car deaths
every year the CDC reports temperatures
inside the car can rise almost 20
degrees within the first 10 minutes even
with a window cracked open Guyton's
daughter was not hurt but she says
that's no excuse for the department
response there's a mom begging you to
come save her daughter's life you send
somebody if I couldn't get the
windshield broken she wouldn't be here
right now they hope the dispatcher knows
they are okay hope it never happens to
anybody else again and I'm just glad
she's okay now according to Waterford
Police the dispatcher involved has not
been back to work since the incident and
will face disciplinary action
the chief says there will be additional
training so that dispatchers know how to
handle these calls in the future but
certainly for any mom or dad watching
this it is a lesson you're freaking out
you can it had us all talking about the
devices I had to break a window Thank
You Michelle